now i would like to introduce to you
somebody who is a rising star in the
scene of science
his name is phil de luna and he is one
of the top researchers in the growing
field of clean
energy featured in the forbes 30 under
30 list for energy
and carbon x prize finalist he will talk
with us today about his work for the
national research council
of canada on hydrogen hello
mr deluna nice meeting you
what is about what is about hydrogen
that
you find so fascinating
well hydrogen is a clean fuel and it
could potentially be the fuel of the
future
when you combust hydrogen and use it the
only emission you get from it is water
so you can imagine in a future society
being able to replace
the majority of our fossil fuel use with
hydrogen
and this is particularly important for
areas which are hard to decarbonize with
electricity alone
hard to abate sectors like
transportation or manufacturing
the sectors that contribute so much to
our quality of life
if we can find a way to move past fuels
that emits co2
then we can find a way to potentially go
to net zero even faster
well if you look 10 years ahead what
would you think
our energy system and our transportation
infrastructure will look like
right that's a great question and i want
to begin by saying that
hydrogen is just one piece of the puzzle
when we think about the energy
transition
there are many different technologies
that need to be at play
battery technologies renewables like
solar and wind and hydroelectricity
uh nuclear technologies whether that's
small modular reactors or next
generation of plants
we really need to think of a whole
approach a holistic approach
that makes the most sense in different
jurisdictions in canada for example
where we're blessed to have a relatively
clean electricity grid
it makes a lot of sense to try to make
hydrogen in jurisdictions like quebec or
british columbia
where we have an abundance of
hydroelectricity
hydrogen is really only clean if it's
produced
from electricity that in and of itself
does not emit co2 and there are
different ways to make hydrogen
and this is kind of the biggest
bottleneck right now which is how do you
produce hydrogen
and do it in a way that does not emit
greenhouse gas emissions
so in 10 years or in the future i hope
to see
a a really a big push towards a change
in transition in our energy
uh systems where we have renewable
energy
capacity like solar and wind and
hydroelectricity
abound and then we have renewable two
hydrogen technologies where we can
then capture that renewable electricity
and store it into a hydrogen fuel
using these new technologies and then at
that point we can have distributed
hydrogen
distributed energy why is this important
it means that
we can reduce all of the emissions that
you would normally see
from large-scale transportation like
air flight or freight or trains or
trucks
and this could be potentially extremely
exciting for
for helping us get to our net zero goals
well that sounds like a great
vision but i guess there are some
obstacles as well to reach this goal
right
absolutely make no mistake this is going
to require a massive
amount of investment in infrastructure
and
on top of that they're a massive
investment in research and development
and
science quite frankly the international
energy agency
released this year its energy technology
perspectives report
for 2020. they analyzed over 800
technology pathways
and they found for us to reach net zero
by 2050
more almost half of the technologies
needed to reach this goal
are not yet commercial which means they
are either
in the lab or at a prototype
or even at a pilot demonstration so
there there needs to be a massive amount
of investment not only
in actually scaling up the
infrastructure for transportation of
this clean hydrogen
for the production of this clean
hydrogen and legalization
but also on the underlying technologies
to help us get there
it's going to take a lot of work and one
of the biggest issues right now
is getting the cost down to move produce
and use hydrogen at the heart of this is
new technologies and catalysts that can
convert
energy into hydrogen or membranes or
systems
so there's there's a lot of work still
to be done but
it's a it's a very exciting time in the
field yeah i guess so and we are looking
forward to
learn more from you in one of the
sessions at the world science summit
thank you so much it was a pleasure
talking to you mr luna
thank you so much